tout est activée nous allons faire un
département justice nous voici dans un
autobus scolaire de pointe claire dès le
premier arrêt
quelques minutes plus tard on a au moins
cinq automobiles qui ont traversé sur le
stop lorsque les feux clignotent et que
le panneau d'arrêt est déployée il est
tôt mobilis qui se trouve devant ou
derrière l'autobus scolaire doivent
s'arrêter
c'est très stressant parce qu'on est
obligés de porter une attention
particulière au débarquement des enfants
qu'on laisse à la maison parce que on
est obligé surveiller nos miroirs avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'attention chaque
jour au québec cinq contraventions sont
données pour ce type d'infraction les
contrevenants sont beaucoup plus
nombreux l'entreprise bus patrouille a
voulu en faire la démonstration
en installant en avril des caméras de
surveillance sur 13 autobus scolaires
répartis dans huit villes au québec
le projet sera étudié sur 13 autobus
c'est un projet pilote qui avait été
annoncé par le ministre des transports
les résultats sont sans équivoque
plus de 10000 séquences vidéo qu'on
analyse et on voit des comportements ou
est ce que ça vaut de la méconnaissance
de la réglementation
je serai des comportements extrêmement
dangereux une poche plastique et
démontrer c'est plus de 3.8 infraction
la moyenne au québec par autobus par
jour
si on prend en compte qu'au québec que
plus de 8000 autres bus scolaire qui ce
qui la nourrit donc ça ferait plus de 30
mille infractions qui se déroule à
chaque jour au québec
les patrouilles a réalisé le même type
d'étude en ontario en 2016
résultat 0,8 dépassement par jour par
autobus
le gouvernement de la province n'a
toujours pas donné suite aux états unis
les caméras de surveillance de
l'entreprise sont installés sur 4000
autobus scolaire dans six états
ce qu'on a constaté aux états-unis c'est
dès la mise en service de nos autobus
c'est une réduction de plus de 35% dans
la première année donc on voit une
baisse drastique des infractions des
ministères des transports du québec a
confié leur rapport du projet pilote un
comité de suivi formé entre autres par
la saq
la fédération des commissions scolaires
et l'association des directeurs de
police du québec
le groupe devrait rendre ses
recommandations au cours des prochains
mois et si marie laurence de l'année
radio canada montréal